-Here's what people
are talking about --
some big news out of Washington.
Today President Trump officially
removed
Anthony Scaramucci
as his communications director.
And this is a little awkward,
when Scaramucci called an Uber
to pick him up
at the White House,
Sean Spicer was driving.
[ Laughter ]
-That's not good.
-Can you imagine the odds?
The odds of that happening.
-Awkward.
-That's right.
Scaramucci lost his job
after just 10 days,
following an obscene interview
with The New Yorker.
You know it's bad when
you get fired after 10 days
and everyone's still like,
"What took you so long?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's bad.
So he's out.
He's out after just 10 days.
So Scaramucci is gone,
but his cologne
will linger forever.
[ Laughter ]
And get this,
Scaramucci's official start date
was supposed to be August 15th.
[ Laughter ]
Or as Trump put it, "See,
we're setting so many records.
[ Laughter ]
"He's the first person
to ever get fired
before they start working."
[ Applause ]
"We're setting so many records."
And it came out that
Scaramucci actually missed
the birth of his son last week
because he was with Trump.
So he -- this is real --
he texted his wife
congratulations.
[ Audience "ohh"s ]
Trump was like,
"You don't text your wife
after she has your baby.
You tweet her."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Tweet.
That's right, last week was
the craziest week yet
for the Trump White House,
and when things get crazy,
the GOP turns to its fans
for support.
Luckily, the GOP's biggest fan
is with us tonight.
So here to offer them
some words of encouragement
is GOP fanboy John Early.
Hey, John.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
Thank you so much
for this popcorn, Jimmy.
[ Laughs ]
-Now, please.
So, what do you have to say
to the GOP?
-To my boys in the GOP,
don't let those haters
get you down!
Despite some minor hiccups
this past week,
and every week before that,
you guys continue to slay
all day!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Now, John, on Friday,
Reince Priebus was forced out
as chief of staff,
after just six months
in the position.
Do you have a message
for Mr. Priebus?
-Keep your chin up, Reince.
[ Laughter ]
Daddy's not -- sorry, Donald's
not mad, just disappointed.
Take your time out to think
about what you've done.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-And Priebus leaving
just came a day after
Anthony Scaramucci
called The New Yorker
to rant about Priebus
and Steve Bannon,
and now he's fired.
Do have any words of support
for Scaramucci?
-Keep telling it like it is,
"Mooch"!
We as a nation love that
you're not PC and/or fake.
Enjoy that time off, babe.
I hope you spend it
like Steve Bannon would,
by sucking your own --
-Oh, hey!
John, John, John, John, John.
[ Laughter and applause ]
John.
-What?
-John, you're on
national television.
-I can't hear anything
you're saying right now.
I think
it's a connection-based issue.
[ Laughter ]
-We'll work on that.
Well, finally the GOP is having
a lot of trouble
getting a new
health care bill passed.
President Trump has called out
the Republican Senators
on Twitter, telling them
they need to repeal
and replace Obamacare.
Anything you want to say
to Donald Trump about this?
-Stay strong, D.T.
You better work!
And by work, I mean needlessly
take away the health care
from the very people
you promised to protect.
Who hurt you?
[ Applause ]
-GOP fanboy John Early,
everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughing ]
And we talked about this
last week.
President Trump responded to
a letter from a 9-year-old boy,
nicknamed "Pickle," who wrote in
to say that he was
a fan of the president.
Well, Pickle actually went on
"Fox and Friends" this weekend.
Take a look at his reaction
to one of their questions.
-You know, a lot of kids write
letters to the White House,
but not all of them
get an answer
from the president himself.
What did you think
when you heard
the president
had read your letter
and wants to be your friend?
What'd you think, buddy?
-What'd you think?
[ Laughter ]
-You're shocked?
-That kid was so good
at avoiding questions,
Trump named him White House
communications director.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow.
-Today.
-Pickle.
Pickle --
Pickle is in the White House.
And finally, I read that
five baby flamingos
were just born
at the Sacramento Zoo.
[ Audience "aww"s ]
And this was nice,
the mother even got a text
from Anthony Scaramucci
saying congratulations.